sydney what is happening so i was
looking for some
i guess some guidance or some advice on
how to deal with not really having a
social support system
my husband and i moved in 2016 about two
hours away from all of our family
and due to various reasons between my
job not having a
culture where you can really make
friends with your co-workers because the
level i was at
and um the dave ramsey journey that
we've been
on and now the pandemic i really just
haven't had much opportunity to make any
real-life friends and i'm sure you can
understand that some online friends are
good but they're not the same as having
someone to work for coffee
absolutely so
i number one thank you for this call
number two i'm living this
right now and sydney i could
be calling you and asking you this same
question
uh overhaul over the holidays over the
thanksgiving holidays um
went back we spent some of it at like i
said at my
in-laws ranch had an awesome time out
there and
it was a blast and then we went and
spent some time with my parents in
another town where
two of my oldest best accountability
friends live
and kevin and michael and one night we
went and sat together
for golly dude i don't know late into
the next morning
or early into the next morning and i
tell you what
sydney mike my soul was healed it felt
good
right and i realized how much i missed
my old friends
so i'm with you i moved to nashville a
few years ago i'm in the same boat here
are some things i'm
trying right now okay and all of this is
in beta
all of this from still figuring it out
and all of this the master word over all
this is intentionality
okay so a couple of things i've done
number one i know the science and the
science is
what you're feeling is is worse than any
sort of
medical pandemic we're having i think
loneliness is the chief
enemy of our time right now and i think
we have outsourced all of our
friendships to clicks and thumbs and
interactions over screens and one of the
sayings i like to run around and say is
we've got four thousand friends on
facebook but we have no one to help us
move our couch
right i've got a hundred new likes on
instagram but i got nobody to help me
change a tire so i can get to work on
time
and we don't know our neighbors we don't
know our friends we don't even know our
church people anymore quite frankly we
don't know ourselves anymore
so all that to say is this here's a
couple of things i've done
i actually have had a couple of families
over to my house
that i had tangential tangential i don't
know how to say that word
i've had related um relationships with
i've known them
here and there sort of had them over to
my house
and they sat down at our kitchen table
me and my wife's kitchen table and i did
this so awkwardly
as i am good at doing i said hey
we'd like to ask you to be our friends
and here's what that means that means
that
we're going to show up at games we're
going to call you guys at 2am if we need
something
we're offering our services to you at 2
am we're going to call you when we're up
we're going to call you when we're down
but i had to say the word to another
grown couple we want to be your friend
one couple sydney laughed they're like
this is super weird
and the other couple the
the guy and he's become one of my close
friends and mentors
he got teary and he said nobody's ever
asked me that question before
which is a whole other conversation to
hold her statement on where we're at
that's number one number two my wife and
i have become hyper intentional about
having somebody out to our place
every single weekend period bar bar none
and some folks have come and they are
from high risk situations and so our
kids run around
in the front yard and we sit on the
front porch
and other times they don't care at all
and they've come into our house and then
i felt weird since we've all gone back
out to the front port
however we're making it work one of the
things that we're doing is being
intentional but the other thing we're
doing is being very gracious so
wherever people happen to be on whatever
health spectrum they are whatever they
believe about whatever
everybody's welcome to the house and our
main goal there is to pour into other
people
be hospitable and to be in connection
with other people
is that working all the time sydney no
is it
weird yeah it is is it awkward yeah
and sometimes it's really great at seven
o'clock this morning before the work day
i was in um communication with somebody
who's become a great friend of ours
here in nashville jp and beth and
they're coming over this weekend we're
going to hang out
and we're going to have to be
intentional about it
i met them at church and i've met some
people at work some people
you know just randomly but it is hard
intentional work
the other thing i'll tell you this
sydney is stay plugged in however you
can to your old friends
whether that's email whether that's
phone calls whether that's it's not
enough it's not as good
but it is a it is just
a drop of cold water in the desert until
this thing's over and we can start
connecting again
so when i tell you those things how does
that rattle around in your head
well i i i really wish i could do some
of those things
but what's holding you back
um all for one we don't really have a
space
or in a tiny apartment okay
um we did used to have some people over
but
they've kind of all like gone off onto
their own lives
since then and stopped really talking to
us are they and we can't really keep
reaching out to people who don't reach
back yeah
so what i'm going to tell you sydney and
i can hear it in your voice is hard
and loneliness sucks
what i'm going to tell you is you're
going to have to keep trying
you're going to have to keep trying and
if that means you got to go meet out at
a park
if you all have to go meet someone in
public space
if you've got friends that you know are
safe and they are well
and you don't mind having them inside
your apartment then so be it
but you've got to keep trying okay so i
want you to think of this
like eating healthy only way more
important
i want you to think of this like taking
your medication but way more important
and i know it feels like rejection when
they don't call you back it feels like
rejection when they don't invite you
i know it does but you got to keep
leaning into it
because loneliness will dissolve you
loneliness will dissolve your marriage
it gets heavier and heavier okay
okay is your husband on board with this
yeah he's actually like the only person
i've seen most of the time
sure are you working on that are you
working
i'm working from home right now okay
and are you at are you at a level in
your company where
it doesn't make sense to have a bunch of
friends because it's just
awkward because of roles and reporting
structures and things
well i tried um like getting to know
some of my co-workers before everybody
went to work from home but i just joined
the company in september
and then we had a big launch in january
so everybody was busy focused on that
and then i kind of started being like a
little more casual with some of my
co-workers and then the pandemic hit and
everybody went home
gotcha so
i want you to be hyper intentional and
this is gonna sound ridiculous
um but it's where we're at right now and
i'm in the same boat as you
i want you to start putting this on your
calendar okay
i want you to put on your calendar i'm
gonna reach out to one person
every day and check in see how they're
doing if possible and talk to them on
the phone even if it's for 10 minutes or
15 minutes
i want you to set up like hey let's have
a drink out at the
at the clubhouse here at the apartment
complex i want to meet you at a park
let's get together for sandwiches my
friend stephanie she's a professor in
texas she's been meeting with students
on her front porch
it's the best they can do and she said
it has been magic for the students it's
been magic for her
whatever it is find a way what you
cannot do
is just fold it up and give up and i
know it feels personal i know it feels
hard
i know it feels like friendship
shouldn't be this challenging you're
right they shouldn't be
that's the season we're in and it sucks
but i can tell you this
if you give up and you fold up you're
gonna really put a lot of pressure on
yourself
you're gonna put a lot of pressure on
your husband and it's gonna be really
difficult for both of you to
cycle your way out of this so you be
intentional you go first
i guarantee you have something to offer
to people sydney i know you do
i know you and your and your husband as
a couple have something to offer to
people
my guess is you are fun my guess is
you're hilarious my guess is you have
all kinds of things to offer folks you
just got to keep trying to keep trying
i'm with you i'm living this with you
sydney i want you to give it a shot for
a few weeks
and if it totally tanks call me back if
it is a disaster call me back
but i want you to have given it i want
you to call somebody every day for the
next couple of weeks
i want you to put yourself way out there
meet for
lunches in the park for early dinners
and drinks
at a clubhouse or a friend's
will come over to your apartment so be
it
don't give up on yourself sydney you're
worth friends you're worth connecting
with